but I think what's actually significant
is not the way that culture was shaped
by TV but the way that TV is shaped by
culture good morning Hank it's two
you're here
welcome to video you have to be aware
thank you so much
um you don't have to say welcome
actually because I am the CEO
and uh it's great he's been doing it
he's been packing socks all day yep
awesomestocks.club I'll tell you what
after spending a day at the warehouse
packing the socks and learning about the
processes that go into getting and
shipping out the coffee and the socks I
believe more than ever in this company
the people who work here are so awesome
as you know Hank I don't want to sound
like a CEO but I've never been so
enthusiastic about a for-profit for
charity Venture in my entire life thanks
for coming out thanks for helping out
yeah it's great to be here I'm feeling
okay right now how are you yeah right
now I'm about to feel worse in about
four days
all right so I want to stop you there
and I want to ask you a serious question
and I know that we've been jokingly
jokity this whole time and that's good I
want to stay jokey jokey but I do think
that like you and I both have this
instinct to in hard times say
it sucks but yeah and we both have it we
put the positive it's very hard to not
say that it's very hard to not say but
when you're talking about difficulty and
what I what I guess I would want to
emphasize is that you are doing amazing
you are as they say tolerating the
treatment brilliantly etc etc going uh
this sucks yeah like you this sucks you
get really sick it sucks
yeah it's for it's legit like the the
quinoa is a reputation that it has
earned oh uh is is how I came out of it
I can count on two hands the number of
times I've seen Hank take a nap
not anymore
and like a bunch of times I've seen you
take a nap it's because you really
really seasick on a boat you don't want
to be on I do that it feels kind of
similar to that like that if you're on a
boat you don't want to be on and you are
kind of Seasick and then nobody else is
on the boat either right you're alone on
a boat on a boat and there's a lot of
people who are on Shore like do you need
anything and you're like I'd like to not
be on the boat and you and then they're
like sorry to stay on the boat that's
the one thing I can't do I gotta let you
gotta stay on the road you're really
Inseparable from the boat at the moment
and I'm like I don't know a lot about
boats and I'm like I don't either but
you got this buddy here's some YouTube
videos about books
YouTube's like would you like boat
videos
I see that you like boat videos
um that means you like boat disaster
videos
I see how much you're enjoying these
boat disaster videos you know planes
also crash
I'd like to show you some plane crash I
know like the chronic illness of other
kinds of illnesses videos because we
have the same YouTube I also experience
this
um and it's great in a way right because
it is just what it says the guy who's
gone on the boat
I see Dad out there just like trying to
save that tree our dad is out and just
making a phone call being like I don't
know if this landscaped a bit to be fair
the tree doesn't look well no it's alive
though so it is work it is worth his
efforts for sure yeah for sure a tree is
on its own boat the trees on its own
boat except the difference is that it's
not alone it has dad there on the plate
I have that too yeah not in the same way
like Dad can't just like stake you to
the ground and be like there you go
stand it straight up again that's Dr
Carl's job we love you Dr Carl because
it's really the biases within culture
that allow infectious disease to spread
right like that's the vector at this
point yeah right we're fairly new to
that yes experience right A lot of times
in the sort of healthcare Journey people
are like why is it so bad
um and like lots of reasons but but it's
easy to forget that a hundred years ago
you didn't expect to be cured of a
disease right the main thing the doctor
told you was yeah like what which which
direction we're headed in yeah so
there's that but there's also the fact
that like it does feel vaguely medieval
a lot of times like the treatment for
chronic illness chemotherapy that like
destroys your immune system doesn't feel
super 21st century to me yeah you know
yeah well the thing is
they're it's it's quite tricky and we
didn't know this until we did it to
distinguish between diseases that are
easy it turned out to be quite easy to
cure right and diseases that were very
hard to cure yeah when when people first
started figuring out how like
antibiotics worked they were like holy
crap and like you know life expectancy
would be 30 years over the course of 30
years yeah and and then they were like
okay well let's do that with cancer then
and they're like it turns out we can't
but through a virus it feels like a
conspiracy yes but it's not it's just
hard right it feels like
cancer should have been easy to cure in
the same way that strep throat was easy
to cure yeah it's not even one disease
like strep throat is one disease cancer
is
it's I have started to think
that it's silly of us
to think of cancer as one disease when
it's like saying a virus like the idea
of a virus is one disease someone in our
family just got diagnosed with basal
cell carcinoma which sounds like a
cancer because it has carcinoma in it
and it is a cancer except that because
the survival rate is 100 nobody really
says they have cancer
right because we associate cancer they
don't even with Jeopardy they don't even
include it in the cancer status I've
learned a lot about cancer in the last
couple months I think
um and one of the I mean one of the big
things we both learned is how uh unequal
access to treatment is like both in the
United States or like in rich countries
but especially between rich countries
and poor middle-income countries
it's shocking yeah even with a disease
that's very treatable and like we know
exactly the drugs you need to get right
and they're not that expensive they're
not
like the Hodgkin's drugs are not that
expensive yeah yeah my chemo is the
cheapest part of my treatment really
it's cheaper than the scams wow now if I
had to switch over to the new one
because a lung problem it would go from
300 of treatment to
15 000. what
what a good system
um Dr Carol mitnick recently had an idea
for me that it never crossed my mind in
my 45 years of being alive which was
what if we treated illness not as an
opportunity
um to maximize value but as an
opportunity to extend the quality and
length of human lives
and like I was like well what how would
we do that yeah and she was like oh
we've done it before
like what's Wikipedia
except an effort to extend the quality
and length of human lives yeah
in a not-for-profit kind of certainly in
the quality anyway I don't know if it's
still that I got it I don't know I feel
like Wikipedia has to already extend the
length of my life Wikipedia was like
here's the here's a concept for you
called micro Morts
which tells you every activity you do
how many minutes of your life does it
decrease wow what's the worst ones
votes I bet
both kind of boats have a lot of
microboards a lot of micro Morts in
boats these days
um boats boats aren't great uh
motorcycles up there not the best you
know what's got even more micromorphs
than parasailing actually is a free solo
rockcom oh I bet that's a heavy micro
more
even if you're good at it and which I'm
not so for me it would be like a million
French Rewards
yeah which adds up to One
Mortgage
you need to get to get to
foreign
there was a pit that you could jump into
to get a squish mallow
okay and my children jumped into the pit
and they each got two squish Metals oh
wow
and it was like a full I watched them
jump it's like 15 feet down and I was
like this is so great because now you
have a squishmallow and you have a
squishmallow and you can both give your
lovely cousin Warren a squishmallow and
they said if you want to give Oren a
squishmallow you've got to jump into the
pit and so I did I look like an eagle in
Flight you've never seen something or
someone So Graceful and the best part is
after I go down through all of the
squish Mallows land deep deep inside the
bottom of this pit of squishmallows the
first thing you hear my squeaky little
coward voice say is well that was
thrilling
hysterical
I have a new chemo symptoms very weird
oh what is it I for the first time in my
life have gotten two ocular migraines oh
like with the auras yeah
I had that one same came after so like I
was passing no pain at all yeah that's
what it usually is it's like warning of
the pain to come and it did hurt very
bad after all right but
I mean much scarier than what it is
because I was like oh yeah yeah because
you it feels like you're hallucinating
it feels like I'm hallucinating yeah it
was in both eyes so it wasn't like an
eye problem it's a brain problem and I'm
like okay this will matter of stroke so
you've got the ocular migraines yeah
that's what really that was really
I was like I can't see Wipeout you know
there's a lot of things that I used to
think sucked Wipeout is a good example
but it turns out that like they're just
a gift of a different kind that's right
they're a show for a different moment
than the moment I'm in maybe but they're
not a bad show there's just a show for a
different person at a different time I
watched like a 19 minute video probably
because you're messing with my algorithm
so much uh that was just every person
who's completed Wipeout over like 25
years wow and it was
they weren't all they weren't all
gazelles but they all did it they all
made it Dude Dad's just doing he's still
at it you know what I think is that the
last shot of the video has to be the
extraordinary work that Dad is doing
thank you maybe alone on the boat but
look how many people are trying to write
that ship if I extended the metaphor too
far anyway dad you're the best we love
you Hank I'll see you right now